let's go next to our caller from the 505
area code who's calling today from 505
hey David this is Isaiah from
Albuquerque hey Isaiah hey I actually
just had a quick question in regards to
my predicting route and definitely hope
is that Bernie takes the primary but if
he ends up going up against Trump in the
general election and ends up losing I'm
serious how progressive might refocus
strategically future elections or how do
you think something like that would
affect political strategy for the
progressive left well we talked about
this on a segment a few weeks ago where
we I laid out how if you look at the if
you kind of game out the different
scenarios Bernie is the nominee and wins
Bernie as the nominee and loses a
centrist as the nominee and wins or a
centrist as the nominee and loses if
Bernie is the nominee and loses to Trump
not only will Republicans say this is a
rejection of left social democracy even
the centrist Democratic party will say
this has been a rejection of centrist of
left social democracy and we should
never again elect someone like Bernie to
be the nominee in the first place so I
think that until it happens we're not
really going to know the repercussions
but there is no doubt that so if Bernie
fails to be the nominee then you will
have the Democratic Party saying see we
told you that those ideas weren't viable
to be the nominee if Bernie is the
nominee but loses the Trump they will
say see we told you that even if the
Democratic party selected Bernie as the
nominee that these ideas would lose to
trump nationally so no matter what they
are going to react in that way the
specific way in which it'll happen is we
were sort of in a wait-and-see on that
definitely do you do you believe that it
would show any sort of out of touch miss
so to speak from the left if Bernie
loses in the sense that there's a real
big platform that
it's grassroots diverse and it's really
what the people want as far as policy go
but maybe it would just be enlightening
in some sense and expose some sort of
misunderstandings that we might have of
the US populace as a whole the thing you
have to remember is when half the
country doesn't vote you can have
policies that are popular with 75% of
the country but based on who chooses to
go out and vote for and against the
policies they might only be represented
say forty five percent at the ballot box
even though they might represent seventy
five percent of all Americans and so
it's tricky and dangerous to extrapolate
too much from that because half the
country or forty-five percent of the
country doesn't even vote definitely yes
that's a fair point yeah unfortunately
but well thank you for taking my
questions David I'm a big fan thanks
Isao hope to hear from you again let's
take a quick break we are going to take
more calls right after this short break
so if you're currently holding please
don't hang up because we are getting
right back to the calls momentarily